elephant's head for the river at the
first light of day they're driven by
thirst here along the Kwon Do River in
northeastern Namibia there's never any
shortage of water that's one reason why
so many elephants gather here during the
dry season but they're having to share
the land with more and more people
farmers like Raymond kitten Baker who
are dependent on the harvest from their
fields he's constantly having to protect
his cornfield from the hungry elephants
we think it all on a TV there were seven
elephants day today papa as soon as we
heard them we ran out to drive them away
but often the elephants aren't afraid of
us and so they just stayed put then they
destroy the fields and suddenly our
livelihood is gone we fear for our lives
but help us now at hand for Raymond
kitten Baker and his family one day with
them without over to say I Verlander
office and I've got Bennett ela KU kala
works for a Namibian conservation group
his job is to resolve these kinds of
conflicts between elephants and farmers
using simple but effective methods he
shows the farmers how they can better
protect their fields we are mixing our
chili with an elephant day that many
people's why we do this is to help our
farmers who are suffering the losses of
crop rating from elephants and then we
use this chili to deter elephant because
our chili it smells more than 28 to an
elephant because an elephant smells a
hundred times than a piston the smoke
from this homemade chili bomb is
accurate and has a similar
effect to tear gas benasi liquor Kayla's
goal is to ensure that the elephants can
continue to live here despite sharing
the space with so many people
he works to help keep the elephant's
age-old migratory routes open so that
they're able to survive and even
flourish gamekeepers employed by the
local authorities regularly patrol these
routes keeping an eye on the elephant's
movements and seeking to preempt
possible problems such as elephants
crossing busy roads yeah we are standing
on the migratory route that is coming
from butanna to Angola to Zambia and
Angola unfortunately dispatches the
trances am busy highway where it could
be danger to wildlife such as elephant
and also people the elephant trails
crossing international borders is
another challenge the kavango Zambezi
conservation area dapped casa is almost
the size of France and crosses five
countries setting it up involved
overcoming both political and physical
obstacles there was a fancy here this
fence is used to start from here up to
the window are almost 20 kilometers so
the fence was removed 770 case
the Caza area is now home to over
200,000 elephants according to estimates
during the course of a year they roam
hundreds of kilometers often straying
outside the National Park but even then
their safety is now largely guaranteed
many local authorities are now profiting
from the wild animals so they've set up
their own conservation areas to protect
them Bennett ela que la stays in contact
with the local community leaders it's
only thanks to their involvement that
the elephant's long migratory routes can
stay open coo coo brothers room by
invisible protecting the elephants has
created jobs for the young people in our
community we also get a good income from
tourism from lodges and campsites then
we also have trophy hunting in our area
hunting firms get licenses which also
bring us a lot of money hunting is an
important part of the conservation
project the shooting quotas for each
area are laid out by the state and are
closely monitored people like folkish
wats who organize hunts pay several
thousand euros for every animal killed
by one of their customers thanks to the
money local authorities can easily
afford to pay for the conservation areas
and for gamekeepers we are mine yuck
possible we have a contract with the
local community directly with a
Conservancy where we basically by our
entire shooting voter when we kill the
animals the Conservancy receives a full
income from us plus all the meat that's
guns of flesh
apart from hunting tourism is the other
big money spinner in the conservation
areas the local authorities allow tour
operators to bring tourists here and to
run hotels in return they get money jobs
and training opportunities for young
people now that private sector like
ourselves has invested onto a property
like this wildlife is actually providing
a financial benefit through tourism so
that already has now an economic value
in the community is protecting that
economic value because over a long
period of time they can receive
financial benefit from the animals
instead of poaching them what people
value they protect that is the simple
principle that explains the success of
this huge conservation project in
northeastern Namibia as a result the
elephants are free to roam almost as
they please even if that means crossing
the odd road or other man-made obstacles